hola que tal el presidente del tribunal
supremo electoral salvador romero ha
explicado que se va a privilegiar la
certeza frente a la rapidez esto
significa que el tribunal electoral va a
ser un conteo de rápidos un conteo de
votos oficial y que va a descartar el
conteo rápido que estaba previsto para
el domingo por otro lado esto significa
que los ciudadanos bolivianos no van a
poder conocer el mismo domingo de parte
del tribunal supremo electoral quien ha
ganado las elecciones y que van a tener
que esperar tal vez varios días a
conocer el conteo oficial según la ley
boliviana se puede esperar hasta siete
días que los tribunales electorales
departamentales cuenten los votos 1 a 1
sin embargo lo que sí se va a conocer el
domingo es el conteo de los medios de
comunicación existe una tradición en
bolivia de que los medios y algunas
organizaciones de la sociedad civil
contratan sus propios conteos rápidos y
sus bocas de urna y los pueden dar a
conocer a partir de las 8 de la noche y
entonces los candidatos suelen también
tomar una posición respecto
a las elecciones y los resultados en
base a los datos que dan los medios de
comunicación en lo político se han
generado varias repercusiones por
ejemplo el ex presidente evo morales
desde argentina que es el jefe de
campaña del movimiento al socialismo ha
señalado que es altamente preocupante
que se haya tomado esta decisión y el
duda de las verdaderas intenciones y el
partido creemos que está tercero en las
encuestas ha pedido al tribunal
electoral reconsiderar esta decisión
porque considera que vulnera el
principio de la transparencia y la
publicidad de los datos
en cambio comunidad ciudadana ha
aceptado la decisión del tribunal
supremo electoral aunque ha lamentado
que esto haya sucedido de esa manera por
su parte la comunidad internacional que
está observando estos este proceso
electoral ha aceptado también y ha
entendido la decisión tomada por el
tribunal electoral a último momento